ladies and gentlemen to present an
honorary award for the Academy and one
was special meaning for those of us who
lived by laughter a man who has lived
with the best of it mr. Danny Kaye
why sir thank you sir
ladies and gentlemen when the fat man
with the Derby hat and the tall thin man
with the sad face first came on the
screen together that was way back in
1926 they made the world laugh at 24
years 24 years and they made us laugh
because in them we kind of saw ourselves
ridiculous frustrated up to our necks in
trouble but nevertheless ourselves
oliver hardy delicately tipped his Derby
head with his pudgy little fingers and
left us a little while back but the thin
sad-faced one the one from whose fertile
minds sprang many of the universally
humorous notions that have been borrowed
so freely by the comedians who are
followed he's still with us
unhappily he isn't well enough to be
here with us this evening but I'm very
proud indeed to except for him from the
Board of Governors this award for
creative pioneering in the field of
comedy presented to one of the really
great men of our chosen profession mr.
stan law
you